you might be wondering
Trump has an event at 4 P.M on a
Thursday in New Hampshire
who goes to such a speech in the middle
of the work day on a Thursday in New
Hampshire well the great thing is we
have video of who goes there let's take
a look they actually interviewed on
right side broadcasting a young guy who
says that Trump inspired him to maybe
run for office one day at school they
tell him he's he's a racist and sexist
but Trump uh has inspired this kid or
something like that look at this the
Future Leaders of America so what's your
plans you're the you're the youngest one
right now in Connecticut uh where do you
see yourself in time I don't even know
what that means I'm the youngest one in
Connecticut but no well I got inspired
by a man you know quite well his name's
Donald Trump
um and my goal someday is to get higher
up in politics I don't really know where
that's going to lead me but I keep the
same principles that he have never give
up never give in Never back down and as
a young conservative I've taken a lot of
heat especially in school I've been
called all the labels racist sexist I've
been yelled at by teachers because I
stood for the Pledge of Allegiance when
no one else would so I've kind of
learned that especially in Connecticut
which is a quite liberal State you got
to stand for what you believe in so I'd
like to maybe move up and run for office
when I'm done pursuing my education you
know get that degree under your belt and
hopefully maybe one day run for a
national office that's what you got to
do I love it let's just give a good shot
on his outfit here I love the uh
[Music]
red pants the kid is wearing
um a blue suit jacket that has white
stars on it it's sort of like a flag
version of a suit I guess I'm gonna move
on without any further commentary on
this one I think it's a minor and it's
just it always a little bit icky but um
I'll just say that that's really really
sad video they then interviewed another
individual who I guess is legally an
adult
and this guy says he's an atheist but he
also is a Christian conservative very
interesting so if I'm open and honest
I'm an atheist but I align more closely
with a Christian conservative worldview
and so
uh I pretty much support Christian
conservatism that horror that whole
moral compass and so that's what I stand
for yeah that I mean that's that's
really sad in that it is so mixed up and
jumbled I'm an atheist but the morality
of Christian conservatism strikes me as
correct therefore
I am going to support candidates who
actually think that I as an atheist
should have a subservient or secondary
status to them because they believe that
we should have a country that is overtly
Christian in terms of civil government
it's all really really whacked now
here's my favorite moment from this okay
there's a remember Ivermectin one of
these
cures that didn't cure nor prevent covid
that was being floated by many on the
right they have a new commercial on
right side broadcasting I guess the guy
who recommended Ivermectin to Trump has
some supplement that will ward off Spike
protein which they have there's almost
nothing true but the funniest part about
this is the the broadcaster on right
side broadcasting her diction is so
terrible and she barely even understands
what she's reading and at one point
refers to Ivermectin as Iver vecten just
I can't imagine they sold any of these
pills based on this ad protein Spike
protein is the toxic substance that
attaches to your cells to allow mRNA to
enter worse both covid and the vaccine
function by using Spike proteins to
attach to your cells many of us have
become overloaded with excess Spike
protein from our surroundings over the
past three years and haven't made the
connection between not feeling 100 this
none of this is true I hope I want to
make really clear none of this is true
it's a grift on a group Rift on a grift
on a grift thin and Spike protein
overload this is a sad reality that we
all have to address fortunately there is
help the chief medical board at the
wellness company including Dr Peter
Mccalla the doctor that recommended
ivervectin ivervectin remember when we
took ivervectin guys and
hydroxychloroquine to president Trump
back in 2020 as well as renowned
epidemic all right so they're selling a
pill that from the guy who brought you
ivervectin they have a pill to get rid
of Spike protein that you might have
absorbed from bananas in the grocery
store it's just the spike is all in our
environment which is really really crazy
then they got back to interviewing
people
they found a guy at the Trump rally who
remember the Trump rally was in
Manchester New Hampshire he came up from
New Jersey Because he believes Trump was
sent by God I think it's very important
to support Donald Trump if not our
nation goes down I believe he was sent
by God to preserve Abraham Lincoln's
promise that at the government of the
people of the by the people of the four
people will not perish but I think it's
rather ironic because I remember
probably nobody else knows this this
Armory in 1976 I was here when I was in
high school and this here's what this is
where Ronald Reagan gave his speech
announcing that he was primarying
President Ford all right so a bit of a
history lesson and then the same guy
mentions that he would also be willing
to take a bullet for Trump and says a
lot of the people at the rally would my
support
my supporter of Donald Trump is
unwavering I would take a bullet for the
man seriously and a lot of us would and
we're gonna even if they wouldn't put
him on the ballot we'd write him in
there you go out totally normal stuff
and by the way let's hope that it is a
write-in campaign that somehow Trump
loses the primary and these folks write
them in it would a guarantee that Donald
Trump loses all right last thing and
then we're going to move on some people
at this rally just a random lame rally
where Trump gave the same speech he
always gives with a little bit of
additional hysteria uh people camped out
overnight after driving up from Florida
I was born to arrived for 45 is here we
came I came from Florida 60th Trump
event we love Trump a lot of us come
across the country to come see the
greatest president ever Donald J Trump
I'm from Tennessee got here last night
flew in oh excuse me you guys got here
was there anybody else in line or oh
yeah they set up the 10 over here and
stuff
four o'clock yes let's go in here real
quickly we heard you guys were here at
four o'clock yesterday setting up a tent
where are you from where are you from
Amanda I'm from New York City the Bronx
the Bronx came all the way down here for
president Trump of course all right so
listen it's a cult we shouldn't for a
moment think that the cult has
diminished as we head into 24. what we
have to hope for and push for is that a
lot of them are just bored because
politics was just a shiny object and now
they moved on and that others will be
tied up with something else and just
won't be as engaged with the exact same
Trump message that he's been using for
six years now and that on turnout we end
up preventing Trump from getting back
into the Oval Office but for if if for a
second you believe the hardcore cultists
are any less interested let those
interviews be proof that that is very
very much not the case